this is scottie tyler broadcasting to
you live from a plane this time we are
throwing everything we have got this
superstar
since its debut in 2012 the forza
horizon series has seen new releases
come once every two years but microsoft
is breaking that tradition with forza
horizon 5 which comes three years after
forza horizon 4. the extra year of
development gave developer playground
games more time to focus and refine the
already solid and much love formula and
to take things to new heights in a new
setting of mexico after spending a few
hours completing the game's first story
missions and taking more time with its
sprawling open world forza horizon 5
seems to be on track to deliver another
solid entry in the popular series
gamespot recently took part in a
hands-on preview event for forza horizon
5 where i got to play the racing games
opening prologue and sample a few story
missions before being set free to roam
the open world of mexico the story
missions were fun and varied taking me
on journeys to help find and retrieve an
old volkswagen or help a friend ride
into a sandstorm to snap a photo of an
artifact the demo also let me try a
series of races involving different
types of cars in a variety of settings
all these were impressive with their
attention to detail and core driving
mechanics but my favorite part of my
limited time was exploring the open road
and experiencing the world at my own
pace that being said forza horizon's
signature showcase events returned and
the one included in the demo was
seriously impressive in this multi-stage
race i zipped through city streets at
breakneck speed launched over ramps and
flew through the air and careened
through trees and the wilderness
the variety of the missions in general
that were available during the preview
was impressive and it kept me interested
in heading to the next waypoint to see
what type of race i might do next what
has made the forza horizon series so
compelling over the years is not only
the various settings it's taken players
to like australia the uk and the bunch
but the way it feels to drive the game's
many cars in those environments and
forza horizon 5 carries forward the
franchise's tradition of excellent
controls once again every mistake i made
in handling a churn or applying the
brakes felt fair and not the result of
the controls breaking down cars handled
better applying the brakes is no longer
an on off type of situation but is
instead a more gradual gripping of the
discs the developer says the suspension
system is improved too with an aim of
making the experience more authentic or
at least that's the idea on paper i
can't say for sure how much i felt the
improved braking and suspension system
specifically but the driving experience
felt very smooth and enjoyable not only
do cars handle well i was using an xbox
controller but the force feedback
controller vibration helps you feel more
closely connected to what's happening
you can in essence feel the tires under
the car and this is especially
pronounced when driving through mud and
over rocks or when you crash land after
a big jump and feel the thud of impact
in your hands the controls reward skill
as well as learning the layout of a
particular track
[Music]
with
599 roads to discover across 11 distinct
biomes of varied terrain in an overall
map size that is 50
larger than forza horizon 4's i was only
able to scratch the surface of what the
game has to offer and i can't wait to
see and do more getting behind the wheel
of a ford bronco and going off-road
through a desert and feeling the thud
and the grip of the mud and water under
my wheels was satisfying while revving
up a mercedes amg and cruising down the
beachside streets and communities was
equally enthralling on many occasions i
stopped and gazed out to the sweeping
vistas of playgrounds version of mexico
and it looks great running on an xbox
series x the draw distances in
particular are quite impressive there's
a volcano on the map and it's visible
from very far away which helped me feel
a sense of place in the world as i saw
it draw closer and closer you can see a
huge amount of the world and it triggers
a sense of wonder as you think about the
many destinations you can explore the
extra year of development for forza
horizon 5 allowed the developers to
create a substantially larger world than
what could have been possible under the
normal two-year cycle adding an extra
year of development not only allowed the
team to increase the scope of the map
but also take advantage of the
horsepower of the xbox series x and s
horizon 5 offers players a choice
between performance mode and quality
mode with the former prioritizing frame
rate at the expense of graphics in the
latter keeping the frame rate at 30
frames per second but boosting the
visuals i enjoyed the smoothness of
performance mode and opted to play that
way for the most part the higher frame
rate made forza horizon 5 feel better
and help me execute hairpin turns and
drifts more easily because i felt i had
a better sense of control and precision
but still in both performance and
quality modes the game looks incredible
beyond the draw distances the attention
to detail was impressive the way the sun
glistens off the hood of a car in the
distance is a sight to behold while the
beachside communities and the cities of
mexico maybe want to stop get out and
walk around that is to say forza horizon
5 does a good job of making its version
of mexico feel alive and lived in as
opposed to simply set dressing for
racing adventures the game's audio and
sound design is seriously impressive too
with the rev and the chug of an engine
standing out to me as one of the most
exciting elements in that regard
another welcome change for forza horizon
5 is that the weather effects do not
apply to the entire map all at once the
developers say if you don't want to
drive through the rain or sandstorm you
can simply drive out of it the forza
horizon 5 preview i attended did not
include multiplayer support with or
against other human characters though
the world didn't feel empty as it had
other drivatars that could be challenged
to impromptu races it's impossible to
truly quantify or qualify what the extra
year of development had on forza horizon
5 but the game seems to be in good shape
right now heading towards launch this
not only gives me hope for forza horizon
5 but also forza motorsport 8 which is
baking for an extra year at developer
churn 10 to hopefully also deliver some
exciting improvements forza horizon 5
launches on november 9th for the xbox
one xbox series xns and pc and it's
included with xbox game pass
stay tuned here gamespot for more forza
horizon 5 at the time of its
[Music]
strap launch in horizon
i've seen this driver before
you